okay let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 is the number we're going to start
with our caller from the five seven one
area code caller please tell us who you
are tell us where you're calling from
and you can jump right into your
question honey pac-man
my name is Grover good to hear from you
again
yes Grover thank you what's on your mind
um so I do have some serious questions
three questions to be exact one why
won't she love me second do you think I
asked you online stream on the stream
whether the Bernese idea will work in
South America and you mentioned it could
possibly work and the third one it's not
a question but I was just wanted to let
you know that you show and other reversi
shows inspiring me to run for president
in my country I agree in the state but I
will run in my country as a burning
crowd again but it wouldn't be burning
Wow
Grover what what is your country ah that
one I'm no Mexican by the way that's
what a lot of people say I didn't say
anything about Mexico I'm asking you
what what is your country
Bolivia Bolivia okay very good
okay Grover thank you and I look forward
to hearing about your candidacy and of
course of course I love You Grover love
all the callers whether they're trolling
me or not so don't don't be good no I
mean that I wasn't trolling you and our
last thing oh sorry my bad I forgot the
last thing okay you didn't cover last
time there was I was a while ago a
little girl who was drinking in water
from the floor it is happening you
native country Argentina okay in
Argentina and I was quite quite a little
bit upset that it wasn't cold about you
even though cuz it wasn't your own
country you know what I mean I don't
know I know you're like you had a lot of
news yeah you know grow I wasn't sure if
just I mean there's a lot of poverty in
a lot of parts of the world including in
my home country of Argentina I didn't
know that some but I didn't think the
girl drinking water merited coverage on
the program necessarily is horrible of a
story
it is but I'll revisit that Grover thank
you I appreciate it